for centuries McAuliffe has been known
as the ancient capital of Wales a small
remote place where most people know each
other but in October last year the town
changed at the time and it was really
sad and tragic place and I don't really
think we've moved on very much from that
I just think it's it's sad it's a sad
place
during the trial the jury pass by mercy
as daily they were visiting the town to
help them understand the case I couldn't
help but look outside the coach went
past and and then the jury actually got
up near here by the clock and had a
little walk down the passageway near the
shop here and that was horrible I don't
know what I expected but they just were
really young and I just kept thinking
though awful awful it was for them to to
have to deal with that the pink ribbons
made in haste and hope still remain but
they are here now in memory what I've
noticed over the last seven months
really is a sort of strong and silent
resilience I think there's a certain
numbness there and as this case is
unfolded there's been elements of shock
about the detail and the terrible news
that's come out the publicity has of
course changed perceptions like
Lockerbie like sown locals gnome
accomplice will be associated with an
horrific crime some describe the mood
here as somber but they're confident
that in time they'll be able to move on
without ever forgetting a
the Solidarity here is as strong as ever
we feel sad especially for April's
family also for the community as a whole
and of course for mr. bridges family who
are still very much part of our town and
nothing which has occurred in the last
nine months should ever be considered to
be at any blame attached to them at all
in the Hills a lone tree covered by
April's favorite colour a space to think
and reflect and perhaps in the years
ahead
to heal Lisa Dowd Sky News McAuliffe